PROFESSOR: So when we start
considering short-range effects
of respiratory
jets and plumes, it
raises the interesting
question of what
is the role of social
distancing, which
is our primary
means for fighting
the pandemic at the moment.
So as we've discussed, this
is especially important
when masks or face
shields are not worn,
so that the jets and plumes
that come from breathing
and speaking and singing and
other respiratory activities
are not blocked, in the sense
that the momentum is not
blocked.
And furthermore, there's
no filtering going on.
So then we have our
long-range airborne risk
coming from respiratory
aerosols that have become well
mixed into the background air.
But we have a new
term that comes
from short-range transmission.
And in a worst case
scenario, we can imagine that
as a wedge-like or
cone-like plume,
which we have just described.
In reality, there is going
to be some background
flows in the room,
which will sweep
that jet in different
directions and break it up.
There'll be motion of
people, turning of heads.
So it'll never be this simple.
But the worst case
scenario is really
a well-formed respiratory
jet and somebody
essentially standing right in
it at a certain distance, X bar,
which is our sort of
average social distance.
As we've discussed, we can also
take the ratio of these two
terms and speak of fs,
which we define here
as the short-range risk
enhancement factor.
So that comes down
to two new parameters
which we've been discussing--
P jet, the probability
that a susceptible person
is in the respiratory jet
of an infected person,
and X bar, the typical distance
over which that occurs.
Xc is this transition distance,
where the respiratory jet
concentration starts to match
that of the background ambient
air, which we substitute and
form this expression shown
here.
So there are a
number of situations
we can think of to estimate
what would be these parameters.
So the first would be just
to consider random occupant
placement.
So in this situation, if we view
from above, we have, let's say,
a person.
This is now viewing from above.
And they have a respiratory
jet, which is going off
like this in one direction.
And then at any
given distance, we
can imagine there's sort of a
typical social distance here.
Now, I'm kind of exaggerating
how far that is compared
to the size of the head.
But if this distance here is
X bar, then at that distance,
we'd like to say, what
is the probability
that the susceptible
person is in the jet?
And that would simply
be formed by taking
the angle of the jet
relative to the full circle.
So we could imagine,
what is the probability
of putting a person right here
versus over here or over here
where they're not
going to be in the jet?
So in that situation,
we could write
that P jet is approximately
the inverse tangent of alpha.
So alpha, remember,
is the ratio--
is the entrainment factor.
And it's sort of the slope of
this line defining the cone
of the respiratory jet.
And then we can
divide that by pi.
So that basically tells
us the probability
of being in this yellow
region versus somewhere
else at a given distance.
And then, now, if we think
about the distance factor--
if it's completely
random, then if we just
imagine lots of people
scattered throughout a room--
imagine a busy
space, for example,
in a bar or a nightclub, a place
where it's somewhat crowded
but people are kind
of moving around.
Then we might have an average
social distance, which
is the area of the
room divided by N.
So that's the area per person.
And then take a square root.
That's an estimate
of the distance.
And the square root of area
is the length L of the room.
So it's divided by
square root of N.
And so with these
two assumptions,
we would then find that this
short-range risk enhancement
factor--
well, what does it look like?
It then is this factor P
jet times Xc over L times--
and then we have this
N minus 1 factor.
So if N is larger than 1,
we could just estimate that
as a square root of N. So what
that shows is as more and more
people pack into the
room, we have an increase
in the importance of long-range
versus short-range transmission.
And this pre-factor here is
something which typically
will be much less than 1,
because the probability
of being in a jet-- if
alpha is around 0.1, 0.15,
this turns out to be around 3%.
OK, so that's-- it's not quite
as wide as I've sketched here.
The jet is a little
bit more narrow.
And we've already discussed
that Xc-- the distance where
the concentration
in the jet starts
to match that of the
ambient-- it does
depend on the
conditions of the room
and the ventilation
and other factors.
But roughly speaking,
Xc is typically smaller
than the size of the room.
And so this factor here is
quite a bit less than 1.
So you see that in
a random situation,
the short-range transmission
starts to become important only
when the number of
people becomes large.
And it grows like
square root of N.
And there's a certain point,
which might be at N equals 20
or N equals 50 or N
equals 100, depending
on the space, where
the short-range risk is
larger than the risk
of the background
airborne transmission.
And that's, again, just
coming from random placement.
So on the other hand, the
random placement situation
is not quite the
best case scenario.
But it's sort of a fairly
optimistic scenario.
The best case scenario
is if people are always
kind of having their
backs to each other,
never breathing on each other.
That never really happens.
In fact, it's more typical in
human interactions for people
to face each other.
They may be talking to each
other, looking at each other.
And so hence, we tend to
find ourselves more typically
in the way of breathing.
And so it might be better
to think about this estimate
in other ways.
So a second way
that we can think
about it is by using
a social distance
guideline, or a social
distancing rule, let's
just say.
So let's say that instead
of a random situation
where people are keeping
sort of the average distance
between each other,
that no matter
how many people in the room up
to a certain maximum occupancy,
they're not going to
come within, let's
say, a 6-foot radius or a
3-foot radius, 1-meter radius.
Depending on what the
social distancing guideline
is in that region,
there's going to be
a certain sort of minimum X.
And let's just think of that
as the worst case scenario.
For the people that are that
close to each other, that's
the distance we'll choose.
And so this might be something
like 6 feet, 1 meter.
You can pick.
And in that case, the
fs is P jet over N
minus 1 times Xc over
X. And we've already
estimated that at
6 feet, Xc over X,
it does depend on the
ventilation and the size
of the room and other factors.
But we've already said
that this factor here
might be something like 6 to 600
for a certain set of examples
that we've just considered.
So when we put
all this together,
if we take into account
also that P jet is around,
let's say, 3%--
if we imagine having
random placement of people
but at a fixed distance,
minimum distance, of 6 feet,
then what we'll
find is this ends up
being something like 0.2
over N ranging up to,
let's say, 20 over N. And
again, this is just very rough.
So this is with random angle.
So in other words,
we're still thinking now
of just this kind of random
orientation of somebody's head,
not necessarily facing
one person all the time.
And so you can see
here that if N is--
if we're in the situation of
the 20, which is-- by the way,
that's the case where
this is getting large.
So that would be a
case of a large room.
Or it would be of low
breathing rates, et cetera.
Then we-- you can see
that when N gets--
if N is small, then this number
can actually be quite large.
So in other words, if we just
have a few people in the room,
and they can get this
close to each other--
like one minimum social
distance, like 6 feet--
then the primary risk is coming
from airborne transmission,
especially if the
room is very big.
If two people are by
themselves in an enormous room,
then the risk from background
airborne transmission
is minimal compared to the
risk of direct short-range
transmission.
So that kind of
makes sense, right?
On the other hand,
notice the effect of N.
If you have more and
more people in the room,
then even though most of those
people are a lot farther away,
there's so many of them
that are potentially
going to get infected
that it becomes worse,
even in the case
of 20 here, which
is sort of the more conser--
the case where short-range
is more important.
It starts to switch to where the
long-range transmission becomes
more important when
N is larger than 20
in this particular example.
So basically, so
significant for small N
and basically large V. So
basically, low-occupant
densities-- if people are
to come close to each other,
then it makes sense
short-range is important.
In fact, a limit that we
haven't talked about yet
is, what if we're outside?
What if we don't
even have-- what
if the V goes to infinity
or V is very large,
so effectively it's infinity?
What this is telling
us is that we
have to stop worrying about
the long-range background
well-mixed concentration
of infectious aerosols.
And instead, we have to
focus on the short range.
Just whenever people are
coming close to each other,
make sure they're not
breathing directly
on each other for
long periods of time.
That's the key.
Now, the last thing
we can think of,
which is really kind of
like a worst case scenario--
that would be where a person is
at the closest distance that's
allowed or expected--
let's say, 6 feet, maybe
even 3 feet, 1 meter.
And also, they're not
randomly placed and angled.
But they're really
just constantly
in the jet of the other person.
So let's say, for
example, P jet is 90%.
That's a pretty high
number, keeping in mind
that there's also turbulent
and chaotic flows in the room,
such that even if you're
facing somebody all the time,
the stable respiratory
jet and puff
train is going to be swept
away by other currents.
And so it's really not as though
the other person is constantly
going to be in--
fully exposed.
But let's just say, we pick a
number like 90%, which is kind
of like a worst case scenario.
And we're always
facing each other.
So let's, again, pick--
X bar is, let's
just say, 6 feet.
Let's just say,
maybe we're sitting
across a table at
a distance which
is sort of an acceptable
social distance
according to the 6-foot rule.
Then we're going to find that
this enhancement factor is
around 6 over N to
600 over N. So we
can see that the short-range
effect can be a lot larger.
So notice, even if N
gets to be really large,
like a lot of people in
the room-- let's say,
it's a restaurant with
100 people in the room--
still, it's 6 times worse
to be in a single person's
respiratory jet 90% of the
time at 6-foot distance.
So that's actually
fairly alarming
if you think about situations
such as restaurants or office
meetings or any
other normal activity
where people are
facing each other
and breathing on each
other continuously
without wearing masks
or face shields.
So this would be--
I'll just mention
here, short-range
dominates in this situation.
So then, how do we
mitigate against
this short-range
transmission risk, which
is going to be worse, again,
when we have people that
are not wearing
masks or face shields
and are in close
proximity and facing
each other for long
periods of time,
and especially in a larger room
and a lower occupant density
where the N is maybe
not so big, and we
don't have to worry as much
about long-range transmission?
Well, one way to
proceed is to continue
using the universal
guideline that we've
derived right here
for long range,
and simply choose a small
epsilon, much less than 1.
And you can see here, it
doesn't have to be that tiny.
From this simple estimate
here, maybe an epsilon of 0.01
might not be so bad because,
see, this number 600 is there.
And if N is maybe 5
or 10 in the room,
then that might be
already helping you.
So remember, we use the
guideline with a fudge factor,
or a tolerance, epsilon.
And some of the uncertainties in
different modes of transmission
are already kind of
included in there.
But certainly, if we're
not wearing masks,
the risk is pretty high.
And so that may not be enough.
And that's why social
distancing can help.
But I want to emphasize
from our discussion
of these respiratory
plumes, there's
nothing really that
special about 6 feet.
There's unfortunately today a
feeling in the general public
that if you're
closer than 6 feet,
you're at extremely high risk.
You've penetrated
somebody's bubble.
But when you're a little
bit more than 6 feet,
you can breathe easy,
because you're safe.
And you can see that's
really not true.
If you are not wearing
masks, these respiratory jets
and plumes can travel
very long distances.
Of course, airborne
transmission is everywhere
in the room at any distance.
But even the elevated risk
of short-range transmission
can extend further than 6 feet.
On the other hand, when people
are turning their heads,
and there's sort of
convection in the room
and thermal convection as
we've been discussing, in fact,
6 feet might be overkill.
Maybe being even a little
bit closer might be OK.
But the important thing is that
distance is not so special.
And also, the details matter.
So as you can see here, we can
get very different estimates
based on where the
occupants are placed,
how they're facing each
other, what kind of activities
they're engaging in,
what kind of movements.
So there's really no
universal guideline.
It makes more sense to start
from a universal guideline
for long-range transmission
and then enforce
mask use in situations where we
are worried about transmission,
rather than trying to guess
how people are going to behave
and what kind of
distance they're going
to keep not wearing masks.
So the safest
thing is, if you're
worried about
coronavirus transmission,
just wear a mask,
indoors especially.
So that brings us now to
thinking about summarizing
this entire chapter, going
beyond the well-mixed room,
where we've been discussing
the fluid mechanics
of indoor spaces and of human
occupants and respiration
within those spaces.
So I think I'd like to leave
you with the picture of people
who are smoking in the room.
So we're all familiar
with the situation
where you have a
room-- let's say,
could be a restaurant
or some other space
where there is,
let's say, a table
or a few tables,
where there's maybe
5 or 10 people in the room.
And there's one person or
two people that are smoking.
Now, we know that when
the person who's smoking
breathes in on the
cigarette and exhales,
there's a very dense plume
of smoke that comes out.
It gets carried by thermal
currents and rises.
And you know that if you
stand right in that space,
it will be a very significant
amount of smoke you're
going to have to breathe.
In fact, it's courteous
for the person who's
smoking to [EXHALES] breathe
away and not breathe directly
in other people's faces.
That would be sort of rude.
And maybe, as we're thinking
about respiratory transmission
of viral disease, we should
think in the same way.
Each person should
be worried about,
am I really breathing
directly on another person?
If I'm not wearing a mask, why
don't I breathe somewhere else?
But we also know
from our experience
with smoke-filled rooms
that there may only
be one or two people smoking.
And you can occasionally see
these puffs or burst of smoke
when they're exhaling after
drawing on a cigarette.
But if you look around
the rest of the time,
the smoke is kind
of swirling around.
It's a little more
concentrated in some places.
But you can see
very quickly, it's
uniformly spread
throughout the room.
And somebody who is on
the far side of the room
is at essentially the same risk
as somebody who's very close--
even 6 feet or 3
feet away, whatever
that special distance may be--
because the air is
typically well mixed.
And those smoke particles
end up throughout the room.
And you're just as
much risk at 60 feet
as you are at 6 feet
under those circumstances.
And so that's really the
main message of this course,
while we also keep in mind that
there are these sort of details
of short-range
transmission that I'd
like you to be aware
of when applying
the guideline for long-range
aerosol transmission.